alright last but not least let's talk
about one of the I guess the more final
looking games we saw Harvey Smith came
on stage to show off this honor to stay
showed off what seemed like a little bit
and then actually just kept going he
showed a lot of gameplay yeah towards
talk about what we saw in that game so
what we saw there was a mixture of what
i saw when i was at arcane yeah along
with a few new scenes so a lot of the
new stuff was surrounding Corvo and
emily being the point where you choose
them so how it works is like Harvey said
the game starts and ends in Karnataka
and the whole thing is I'm sorry in
dunmore right or in between it's kanaka
so the whole point of it is like as
Emily you have ascended the throne and
now you've been usurped right which back
to karnak away you've gotta figure out
who's causing the kind of like revolt
against you and you go back and reclaim
the throne so the inciting incident has
a start is where you pick who you want
to play as and then we basically got a
showcase of scenes the different like
areas of the game which look stunning
yeah looks amazing that was the devoid
engine at work like they've got some
whole new crazy lying stuff going on
which looks really nice and we got lucky
showcase of Emily's powers covo has
changed based on what I saw Coronel
voiced by steven Russell as well of the
the voice of garage for thief which like
it was such a wonderful way of them
saying yo this is where thief was like
were the new thief oh so Koval has
changed but a lot of its like subtle
tweaks to his existing abilities that
make him a little more interesting to
play right whereas a lot of Emily stuff
is where all the new stuff is and will
not see stuff like shadow walk which is
a kind of stealth power that you get
around in a way that's a little more
sneaky but obviously enemies will see a
shadow moving around so it's more like
if you want to set up a strike there was
one called mesmerize i think it is way
right or that obelisks thing appear and
it's basically like you put that in the
middle of an environment and anyone that
sees it is like what the hell is this
all about r into a different dimension
yeah and they just kind of gather around
it and I like entranced by it and then
we also got to see the coolest power
forgot the name Domino omen on there so
it's like you basically you link a bunch
of people together to create a view link
everyone in the game yeah
on the head and like anything that
happens to one of them happens to all of
them and it didn't show it here but they
explained the shoulder to me in my demo
of it so like if you link one person to
a bunch of enemies and kill that one
they all die or what you can do is Emily
can summon a doppelganger of herself and
then link that doppelganger to her
enemies and then she can just like
plunge a sword into her own what friend
friendly that is going crazy and watch
everyone just how do they stop people
from like exploiting that's the point of
this honored right they want people to
figure out weird ways to break the
system okay and figure it out and tell
people they just hope that they're the
kind of simulation is robust enough to
even not completely fall apart or to
accurately kind of respond to that any
interest I mean like this is Harvey
Smith who worked on deus ex which is the
poster child for emerging gameplay so
more at it Alexi you were freaking the
hell out when she brought out her like
time fan yeah the time that was shadow
walk right where she was shadow is the
the other one this is some new pope I
Diana worth it's now the time sure and
she had the time fan and no I just
knowing that all those powers exist like
Emily feels like she's really Opie
totally but knowing that those powers
exists and I have all of that at my
disposal makes me really excited to play
the game because it means the game is
gonna put challenges in my way yes that
will force me to find creative ways to
use all those powers in tandem so is
madness this is I'm just so freaking
cool just jump back in time and and
stabbed a dude and then jump back again
and then everything also looks beautiful
yeah it looks incredible yeah Alex qua I
think I'm really looking forward to is
if you go to youtube now and type in
like dishonored one speedruns all
montages the stuff that people are doing
is just absolutely insane and like with
all these new powers the things that
people are going to come up with its
going to be mind-blowing you know you
need a certain level of predictability
to to AI and that kind of stuff and
we're just watching the community figure
all that stuff out over the next couple
years and then finally get to the point
where they can like just ballet their
way the entire idea this is going to be
really interesting to watch on off to
watch way too much longer to get to it
November 11th 2016 is when we will
finally get to get our hands on desire
to and it looks fantastic